hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher I think one of the biggest
challenges at the moment in teaching
mathematics is that in Australia our
syllabus is not really structured to
encourage mastery in fact it's
structured to encourage people to move
on through a series of ideas and be
exposed to them but not necessarily you
really get them at a conceptual level
and to illustrate how this would look
different I mean if you ask someone you
know oh you play the piano and you're
grade eight you know how old are you
well the answer is however old they want
to be there might be six years old or 16
or 60 and we say you can play that level
of piano whenever you are ready for and
when you can develop those skills but
somehow we say you're 15 years old you
must know trigonometry by now that's
crazy to me when everyone has such a
different mind such a different set of
gifts and talents and skills and also
such a different journey that they've
come from different contexts where the
background the different teaching that
they have been able to encounter will
they've given them a deeper or a more
shallow experience of those different
concepts so for me to be able to say to
a student I am going to give you help
you experience the learning that you
need now that makes sense in your
particular instant in time for me the
structures around the syllabus make that
very difficult because I standardized
testing means we've got to move on
forward you're getting into stage six
well I guess I have to finish all Stage
five whether you're ready for that or
not so for me that's the big struggle
and I know that's a really difficult
thing to work with because we have
curriculum requirements at the same time
I think we owe it to our students that
we need to wrestle with that and not
just say sorry this is the best that we
can give you I don't think it is I think
we can push on that gently to try and
expand the envelope of what our students
can experience so it makes sense to them
at their moment
you